[Applause]
thank you senator Bernie Sanders is a
long way from winning the Democratic
Party nomination but the question now is
who can beat him introduce to you the
next First Lady of the United States he
and his wife Jane had already headed
from Nevada to Texas which will vote the
week after next in Nevada we have just
put together a multi-generational
multiracial coalition which is gonna not
only win in Nevada it's gonna sweep this
country
[Applause]
he pulled twice as well as his nearest
challenger former Vice President Joe
Biden who still thought that was worth
celebrating
you know the press is ready to declare
people dead quickly but we're alive and
we're coming back and we're gonna win
[Applause]
Nevada isn't big enough to deliver a
knockout blow to any of the also-rans
and until some of them quit it won't
become clear which of the survivors is
best placed to challenge
senator Sanders it's hard to see a way
back for either of the remaining female
candidates Elizabeth Warren and Amy
Klobuchar p-put a judge wants to be seen
as the moderate alternative and sounded
a warning before we rush to nominate
senator Sanders in our one shot to take
on this president let us take a sober
look and what is at stake for our party
for our values and for those with the
most to lose Mike Bloomberg entered the
race so late he wasn't even on the
ballot in Nevada but the former New York
mayors enormous personal wealth means
he's in it for the long run but the
Democratic Party is facing up to the
reality that a far-left candidate will
have to appeal to America's Center
ground if they're to win back the White
House in woods Sky News Washington